.
>> MY PLEASURE.
>> SOME OF THE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS WHO MAKE MONEY BY
MUTILATING THE BODIES OF YOUNG
WOMEN ARE BEING SUED FOR WHAT
THEY'VE DONE.
THE CASE IN POINT IN 2020 AT TH
AGE OF 30, CAMILLE KEEFE ALSO
SHE WAS APPROVED FOR A DOUBLE
MASTECTOMY AFTER A FEW VIRTUAL
VISITS WITH DOCTORS AND GENDER
CLINICS AND THE STATE OF OREGON
SHE IS SUING THE SOCIAL WORKER
AND HER THERAPIST AS WELL AS TH
CLINICS INVOLVED HERE AT SHE
JOINS US ALONG WITH OUR HER
ATTORNEY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
TONIGHT.
I UNDERSTAND THE OUTLINES OF
YOUR SUIT, BUT TELL US WHY YOU
THINK YOU WERE WRONG?
APART FROM THE LEGAL CASE YOU'R
MAKING.
>> SO PART OF IT THAT WAS THAT
SOUGHT OUT.
>> IT'S OKAY, I'M GOING TO GIVE
YOU A SECOND TO COLLECT YOURSEL
AND ASK YOUR ATTORNEY ABOUT THE
CASE THAT YOU ARE MAKING AND
MAYBE YOU CAN FILL IN SOME OF
THE EMOTIONAL BLANKS.
WHAT ARE YOU ARGUING ON BEHALF
OF YOUR CLIENT IN THIS CASE?
>> THANKS.
THIS CASE IS ABOUT MENTAL HEALT
PROVIDERS WHO BREACHED THEIR
DUTY OF CARE AND VIOLATED THE
PROFESSIONAL ETHICAL STANDARDS
AND THE STATE OF OREGON LEADING
TO IRREPARABLE HARM TO CAMILLE
AND DOING SO BY MAKING FALSE
REPRESENTATIONS TO MEDICAID.
>> THEY MAKE MONEY BY DOING THIS
.
WHAT IS THEIR OBLIGATION, WHAT
IS THE OBLIGATION OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE TREATED CLIENT THEY DIDN'T
MEET SPECIFICALLY?
>> THEY HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
TREAT THEM AS AN INDIVIDUAL AND
TO TREAT THEM ACCORDING TO
EVIDENCE-BASED MEDICINE.
AND THEY TOO THEY MET HER ONE
TIME EACH AND WROTE A LETTER TO
HAVE HEALTHY BODY PARTS REMOVED.
ON THE BASIS OF IDENTITY THAT.
>> THAT SEEMS PRIMA FACIE
IRRESPONSIBLE I CAN'T IMAGINE
ANYBODY WOULDN'T SEE THAT AS
IRRESPONSIBLE, CAMILLE, DID YOU
FEEL LIKE THEY CARED ABOUT YOU
AS A PERSON, CARED ABOUT MAKING
YOU BETTER AS A PERSON?
>> I THINK THEY WERE HIGHLY
INFLUENCED BY IDEOLOGY AND THAT
IS IN OUR MEDICAL SYSTEM HAD
THEY LOOKED UP THE UNDERLYING
HEALTH ISSUES WHICH AS THOSE
RESOLVED, I REALIZE THAT I WAS
NINE BINARY THAT I WAS A WOMAN
ALL ALONG AND HAD BEEN DEALING
WITH TRAUMA THAT I WOULD'VE
NEVER NEEDED THE SURGERY, SO
THEY HAVE RESPONSIBILITY TO
THEIR PATIENTS TO LOOK AT THING
FROM A NUANCED PERSPECTIVE AND
NOT BE INFLUENCED BY IDEOLOGY.
>> THEY HAVE BEEN TREATING
CANCER PATIENTS LIKE THAT, NO
ONE WOULD SURVIVE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT, I KNOW IT'S
HARD FOR YOU TO TALK ABOUT IT.
THANK YO